[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu as nounours poton jus faux mon pauvre
nounours
j'espère que pimprenelle aura quelques
bonne tartine de miel à t'offrir on nous
pas de viol pour du lourd ce soir on va
se faire une bonne petite soupe à
l'oignon ati une excellente recette une
petite recette de derrière les fagots
pas trop mon le cheval sont les loups à
la bouche
rien que d'y penser nous goûtons le nom
doux bonsoir j'ai compris ce qu'ils sont
intelligents
c'est petit
[Musique]
ce soit mais son fonds chefs votre
chapeau grands cuisiniers
merci le petit jardin chef by nicolas je
crois qu'on va bien shapé ce soir mes
enfants c'est la soupe à l'oignon la
balagne en voyons froid savons non c'est
pas ça
sa voix la soupe à la célestine à la
colle beurre ou perles du japon au
tapioca à la moi j'aime pas ça soupe au
chou soupe à l'oignon
[Musique]
faire revenir aux casseroles est
tendrement 15 grammes d'oignon finement
thema insu avec 150 g de beurre et voilà
la mer ceux du punch au moins
oui nanard bon lorsque les oslon sont
bien dorés
nous laisserons aux poudres et d'une
cuillère est de farine ajouter à un
litre et demi d'eau tiède recouvrir de
fromage râpé faire gratiner dans un four
de préférence chaud
ce que ça va être pour un couteau s'il
vous plaît j'épluche des zones on voit
la chef un kikoo moi je rappelais
fromage les colonnes qui suit la
casserole qu'elle tu vas bien propre à
elle va être à pékin taquin sera latmos
il en faut beaucoup de fromages mais
nous oui oui aubonne et voilà qu'est ce
que j'y mets dans la casserole du bourg
neuf cas ce qu'annonce 4
[Musique]
nous non plus les oignons sous les faux
pas ferait ça me fera du bien
mes propres yeux
peut-être le moment quand il fait la
ligne même si la télévision il pleure
pas lui il est gros allô prof à petite
échelle
comment ne s'étant pas trop ça me fera
du bien que respirera de l'hercules nom
valait ce que j'ai comme des grands
bonne nuit et nous à demain bohui maison
ro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre nous notre cher nounours n'est pas
un très bon cuisinier
ils devraient savoir que les oignons ça
pique les yeux et ça fait pleurer allons
compagnon et suit tes larmes au patro
que le choc water bottle mots aux routes
nos noces auront new look bonne nuit les
enfants fait doux rêve de dou born
[Musique]
oh
où